a lot of viewers wanted to see some of
their favorite video game systems go
head-to-head so we decided to give
something to everyone because today
we'll be putting 12 retro systems
through a series of trials if they break
they're out and we pick one winner from
Super Nintendo all the way to ps3 pick a
side and let's get started
[Music]
the console wars started in the 90s with
the 16-bit Super Nintendo outselling
Sega Genesis by about nine million units
hold on to your bits consoles we're
taking you to the battle ring I'm a
Genesis guy love sonic don't get me
wrong Mario's great but Super Nintendo
never owned one I used to have my Super
Nintendo and Mortal Kombat 2 hooked up
to a 4-inch black-and-white portable PA
my bedroom a four inch TV and now I have
bad vision weird
[Music]
oh god what have I done
okay so structure looks pretty good but
the power switch is filled with wonky
supers still got its controller and lost
its game
power buttons little one for two Eric
and now you love your Super Nintendo so
try it first
okay the switch I have hope alright next
both companies up their bits with the
n64 and Sega Saturn than Sony introduced
the first PlayStation and outsold both
its competitors alright so we're about
to do
second generation lot hours playing
these games and not talking to girls
this is essentially the default version
of an n64 just an n64 with goldeneye in
it yeah there's not many other kinds I
know
[Music]
the n64 cord cuts extra damage points
because it's 64 is in midair and then a
cartridge it's like train collision all
right what's the damage
it looks significant look at the satyr
and it's just like ready for action all
right let's plug them in test them
carefully Sega Saturn let's see what
happens
even if it powered up I don't think we
couldn't even open the tray cuz the tray
bug is gone nope
done PlayStation original good
interesting problem here the case won't
shut all right whole teamwork okay ready
yeah
okay PlayStation done now this guy
we're both rooting for this one family
do we got light
we got a game all right okay just turn
the cameras off will we be a couple
hours looks flawless and I think
cartridge games I mean they're great
I'm just gonna leave thank you in the
next generation the cartridge was
totally dropped in all systems wind disk
just in time for Microsoft to complicate
the war even further with the Xbox for
consoles at once the original Xbox is a
beast
this thing is lol huge
[Music]
holy cow that was a lot of destruction
that's like a four car pileup let's plug
them in and test them let's go ahead and
talk about the two that I don't think we
can even test Xbox one original base
plates go and why that's so important is
it's the power button and a little wire
clip attaches deep inside the system so
okay there's no fixing her even on ps2
shifts in so many pieces oh we
definitely can't test this this this is
a DVD Drive so now the Dreamcast I think
this one might be something you had one
of these right oh yeah I love my
Dreamcast so I hope it turns on beeping
it's a longer beep than usual booting up
that's good and I'm playing games all
right green cast unimpressed last but
not least in the generation at GameCube
this could do it is it spinning you hear
anything I don't think so yeah then the
lunch box out to lunch so only the
Dreamcast survived this generation
Tanya's got fourth generation all right
[Music]
this takes us to the last generation
will be testing sega was finally put to
rest but the battle raged on with the
wii 360 and ps3
hey guys feelin the 360 this thing is
gonna red ring if it doesn't explode and
this is actually my personal xbox 360 so
the one that we got off eBay red ring so
we had to use mine but that's not my
hard drive on there right no no we
switch the hard drives yeah yeah of
course you're okay great answer sorry
guys
[Music]
how does the PlayStation 3 look I think
it's uglier tough to do
oh hey Xbox the Xbox evacuated the scene
of the crime the front popped off but
other than that it looks pretty good I
think that I think it like lying around
the harddrive it's still gonna red ring
there's no way this red ring will see
and then we the little front plate came
off what the we looks totally fine let's
plug them in start the week okay that's
that's not a good sound that was like an
angry sounds like well oh oh it's
working okay I'm trying to feed it the
game aren't you hungry it's so angry he
was like pissing sounds like an angry
wombat
push harder oh I think I just like
wedged in between okay it turns on but
you can't really play game lets you
download it in PlayStation 3 ugly then
it's got the spider-man thought come on
not lighting up or anything no it's a
piece of garbage your personal personal
xbox360 there's the thing a green light
is on no it's not red ringing because it
fell from 15 feet
wait there's no way it works ha ha yes
bungling hey wow are we gonna call the
360 the clear winner here
yeah I mean you can't put a game in this
has this is fully functional it's got
character yeah
[Music]
for our second test we made our own
special blend this is battle do let's
say a late night video game session and
get some battle do on your console will
it survive we're gonna find out
[Music]
John will they blew it up we electrocute
ourselves find out custom all right we
just doused these in battle do let's
carefully turn them on and we're all
wearing gloves don't try this at home
let's hit the power well okay let's see
what explodes first I heard beeping the
frickin Dreamcast booting up like a boss
it doesn't even need to hit be turned on
no it's like I'm ready guys it's so
caffeinated
okay well the Dreamcast has chosen his
own time okay it's working let me use my
magic touch in the Genesis good hmm nope
OSS is dead in 64 Pierce lights on and
you're like a humming okay sorry now
your ex by my first lunch box here we go
I think your xbox is dead bro the answer
is clear the Dreamcast was as I thought
the best system ever made maybe not the
most popular system of all time but a
good system nonetheless and clearly the
toughest even though I was glad to see
the Dreamcast win a lot of brave systems
did lose their lives today and so ends
the console wars
Justin what are we gonna do now we've
destroyed all our video game systems
I'll be fine
I've still got this that's pretty cool
what if we battle-tested it don't you
dare touch cubby I'm really good at I
hit my face